hey we partnered up with a company
called dreamworld to bring you exclusive
anime merch that you can't find anywhere
else if you love demon Sayer we've got
tons it off my boy sided soup and so
much more check it out at enter
dreamworld com
or click the link in the description
what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
talking about demon king ton judo if you
enjoyed these Demon Slayer videos and
want to keep them coming the best thing
you can do is smash that like button and
share this video we cover a lot of anime
on this channel and it's always fun to
see what the fanbase says favorite anime
is and one way we can judge is by number
of likes
so if Demon Slayer is one of your
favorites be sure to absolutely destroy
that like button let's see if we can get
something epic like over 10,000 likes if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial ring that notification
bell or you will miss future Demon
Slayer videos right now YouTube ad raise
have significantly dropped so the
support we get from our patrons over on
patreon is now more important than ever
our glorious patrons help make videos
like this one possible so thank you all
more on you amazing people at the end of
the video and if you aren't a patron but
are interested in supporting this
channel you can check out the link in
the description or visit patreon.com
slash anime out drawer for now keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers in
this video you've been warned now
without further ado let's jump into it
so what do we know about demon king
tundra as of now well in the last
chapter Tundra hurt cano while she
succeeded in getting the medicine inside
him we don't know how heard Cannell is
for sure she used Vermillion eye which
causes insane pressure on the eyes with
her one remaining eye so she could very
well be totally blind now or even dead
she got what looked like a serious
injury from tundra and she was already
in bad shape to begin with at the end of
chapter 202 Natsu Cole was crying and
calling out Connells name while even
demon king ton judo had a face that
looked like it was filled with remorse
that's the first time he had a somewhat
human expression on his face since he
became a demon these events have led
some fans to believe that this is the
end of demon king ton zero so I thought
it would be interesting to make a video
discussing if we've seen the
of demon king Tundra and if not how he
might eventually be defeated so we have
some important questions to answer here
is this the end of demon king tundra now
that the medicines in tangier oh is he
going to be human again in the next
chapter is this demonic nightmare behind
us already are you going to smash that
like button well in regards to demon
Tundras fate I really don't think he's
met his end yet and I'll explain the
reasons why we were introduced to demon
king Tundra in the previous chapter
chapter 201 so is it realistic that he'd
be defeated in chapter 202 knowing this
mangaka that doesn't seem likely the
Mouzon fight has pretty much been going
on since chapter 180 you can say he was
defeated in chapter 200 although the
demon King's Tundra fight is sort of an
extension of the moves on fight - but at
the very least that one battle lasted 20
chapters so it's very unlikely that a
crazy plot twist like demon king tun
Judah will only last one or two chapters
the Demon Slayer mangaka gotaga is a
master and lover of Reverse uno cards
whenever something looks over it's
usually not for instance remember how it
looked like lower moon five ruies head
was cut off by the combined efforts of
time Joana Zuko next episode it's
revealed that he detached his own head
so that he could avoid the slash and
survive and when all hope looked lost GU
shows up and wrecks him that's at least
two owner reverse cards right there you
can see this in practically every
fighting demon slayer think about how
upper moon six Docky appeared to be
defeated only for her stronger brother
guitarra to show up think about how akka
sews head was cut off by a self estate
ton zero only for his head to grow back
and then even more shockingly he gives
up the will to fight and self-destruct
if the fight against upper moon one
Kakashi bold lasted from chapter 165 to
chapter 179 practically 14 chapters I
think demon king tundra is gonna get
more than two chapters the other thing
to consider besides go to Gay's
storytelling style is the foreshadowing
she placed earlier on why did Mouzon
choose Tundra to be a successor because
he would become immune to the Sun like
desert oh and
because he was a user of the breath of
the Sun style the strongest breath style
so far demon tundra has not used the
breath style as we've seen other demons
do namely Kai Goku who used breath of
the Thunder style as a demon and Kakashi
Bo who used breath of the moon style as
a demon
thus I feel like people would feel like
it was rushed and like the concept a
demon king Tundra was not fully explored
if we don't get some more demon king
tundra and see him using some demon sun
breathing not to mention that it would
be completely against the mangakas past
patterns of prolonging battles
especially when they are important ones
anything is possible we've been seeing
fights after fights with no break for a
while but I feel like it's still too
soon for tundra to already be going back
to normal
there's a reason he still has demon eyes
after all and even when we think of mezu
KO we have to keep in mind that she
didn't become human right away it took
time and she had even less moves on
blood in her than tons II don't remember
that Mulan said he put all of his
remaining blood and power into time judo
so I think it's safe to say that we
haven't seen the end of the man King
time show yet as usual the last chapter
was a cliffhanger to keep us on the edge
of our seats I think that kana will
survive because we know that if a demon
kills one human they can't go to heaven
we saw this with son amis mom she
couldn't go to heaven because she killed
as a demon even though she had no idea
what she was doing at the time I can't
see tundra our kind-hearted protagonist
not going to heaven so chances are Kanna
will survive but I fear that her vision
might be gone so how is demon king
Tundra gonna be defeated how will he
meet his end well in my view it won't be
the result of a physical battle since we
know that Tundra is practically
invincible now he's immune to the Sun
and he should be able to easily
regenerate from every wound including
having his head cut off in fact he has
more Muslim blood than a Kazan kakushi
bow did and they could both regrow their
heads if we look at past fights like the
fights against akka zankoku she bow the
mangaka has established a pattern of
demons being defeated not through
physical power but through the fighters
somehow getting through emotionally to
the human inside the demon we also know
that moves on picked Andrew because he
shares as close blood and so he assumed
that tundra will also become immune to
the Sun his assumption was right but at
the same time that means that the
medicine should be effective on him and
if mezu co even while she was a demon
could overpower the demon impulse to
kill humans
then tundra should be able to do that in
theory - even though he has much more
moves on blood
so what I'd expect to see is some more
reverse uno cards I'd like to see what a
demon enhanced breath of the Sun user
would look like but eventually if not
sooner I expect that perhaps with some
help from the medicine Kendra's friends
will succeed in getting through to him
emotionally
if Tundra could get through to Akasa and
I'm sure the tundra sister and best
friends should be able to get through to
him eventually some people may not like
this and call it Todd no jutsu
but demon slayer has always been this
kind of story and I personally don't
think it's a bad thing
the good guys usually beat the bad guys
without being stronger than them
physically either through a well
orchestrated plan or through reaching
the emotional side of the enemy the
mangaka has trained us to expect this so
I wouldn't be surprised or upset
especially since the mangaka usually
execute this in satisfying ways I also
don't think Tundra will need to die it's
very very very rare for a shounen jump
battle manga protagonists to die and
stay dead last time I said this some
people have pointed out that Jonathan in
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure part one dies
but he was also only around for nine
episodes before we get the new
protagonist Joseph and after Jonathan
the other protagonists continued to
survive and appear in further seasons
not to mention that JoJo's eventually
got transferred over to a seinen manga
magazine which is for older demographics
than Shonen and primarily aimed at dudes
in their 20s to 50s so I think it's
pretty unlikely that Tundra will die in
fact he needed to become a demon for him
not to die and for his face to go back
to normal
since he got that huge infection from
Mouzon it is only by becoming a demon
that he could heal his arm face and eye
so it's actually been set up that now
when this battle is over Tundra will be
back to normal
there's also a hope that Demon Slayer
might not be over yet either after this
even though Mouzon was the main
antagonist from the beginning we might
get more arcs look at black clover
I had the Midnight Sun was the main
enemy since the beginning and then when
that was all resolved they found a way
to continue the story and demon slayer
is also very popular too in fact it was
the best-selling manga series in 2019 so
you know that Shonen Jump who came out
with Porto after Naruto 700 chapters is
going to be pushing for some kind of
demon slayer continuation Musleh has
also given us some hope for a
continuation since he said that tundra
will become the king of the demons well
it implies that there are more demons
out there and they will obviously have
to be handled by the demon Slayers or
demons will continue to pose a problem
and if Mouzon could be turned into a
demon then so could others there could
even be older more powerful demons than
Musa who have yet to reveal themselves
so there's room for the series to
continue any way you look at it the only
thing is if the manga has adamant about
ending the series then it'll have to end
but that's not the norm especially when
she's only about 200 chapters in so if
the medicine eventually works we might
see time she'll continue being a Demon
Slayer to get rid of some new threats or
it's even possible that he remains an
Opie demon but continues to fight for
the good guys like you Shino Tamayo and
a Zuko did after all the mangaka has
really emphasized the fact that not all
demons are bad over the course of the
story you can't judge a person based
solely on their demonic cells so that's
what I'm thinking I think we haven't
seen the last of demon tonzura
there will at the very least be a more
drawn-out conclusion before he turns
back to human if he turns back to human
at all either way I predict that he will
survive and that he won't kill anyone in
the process although he may come close
to help build suspense as he did with
Kanna there is also the possibility of a
continuation which should be more likely
than not but in the end it's gonna be up
to the mangaka and whether she's cool
with keeping it going
sometimes mangaka may want to move on to
other projects and other series but i
think it looks good that Demon Slayer
only has 200 chapters while most other
popular shounen jump manga including one
piece naruto bleach black clover and my
hero academia have gone well beyond that
number let me know what you think about
all this stuff will there be a
continuation who will be the next
villain and how
they defeat the demon time Jiro will he
meet his end or will he continue to
fight for the good guys as an Opie demon
if so I really hope we see him using his
breath on the Sun style in conjunction
with his demon powers as far as power
scaling goes I think the mangaka has
done well and left room for a lot more
powerful opponents and for the main
characters to grow stronger and that is
it for today's video thank you so much
for watching if you enjoy these demons
hair videos I want to keep them coming
the best thing you can do a smash that
like button and share this video with a
friend and if demons there's one of your
favorite anime that we cover make sure
to really destroy that like button to
let the world know your undying love for
demon slayer let's see if we can get
something epic like 10,000 likes that's
right 10,000 if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial ring that
notification bell or you will miss
future demon slayer videos leave
suggestions for what demons there videos
you would like to see next in the
comments lastly the YouTube ad rates
have significantly dropped recently so
the help and support we're getting from
our anime out to our patrons is now more
important than ever a very special thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon and WAP has survived these
YouTube issues and who helped make
videos like this one possible first and
foremost I want to thank the legends
acknowledged by Lord Twigg o himself
baby ray and Efrain age and the one tier
patrons the ones who stay atop all clans
Steven and Radha a Lola and autumn the
world stealers the school bus Theisen
Kirino acquire respect but a heffa
Jonathan King and sed and our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson Kings
I'll just Anatoly Cassatt Suki angel
Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket
XP Ted Note edge altar Joel Stanton
Barry Gucci Alicia actor animal 69
jessica calif on he no kami and water
Bonnie parks is OD art 12 wrath doing
the hora and protocool JCC waka and the
coach thank you all so much if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon calm an Emir Pro
and becoming a patron today for as
little as one dollar if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here annual
even get access or private patron only
this course where we talk about anime
life and of course dankmemes so check
out patreon.com slash anime uproar
link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
YouTube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you will get the
same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you